allora ragazzi come sono andate queste
vacanze vi siete ricordati abbastanza
immagino vi ricordo che quest'anno c'è
la maturità è quindi non si scherza più
ma viene annunci ma ti quest'estate
come capire se davanti 55 centimetri se
siete due metri allora iniziamo subito
che siamo giunti fuoco un programma
piuttosto sono stata clemente ma
quest'anno bisogna la vo quest'anno sarà
tutto in salita è così avevo avuto tre
mesi per leggere 18 livi adesso vivente
via caneva tenuto tempo quest'anno si
tocca al registro di tutti i sensi
questo sarà l'anno decisivo e chi studia
di volta in volta è a metà dell'opera io
ve lo dico sei credibile ma lo faccio
mai visto bene allora se iniziando poi
l'ho già iat mica gli esami e quest'anno
di bocce spunti benedico lo avevo dove
le vacanze sono finite
mi avete avuto di tempo per divertirvi
adesso bisogna studiare dove la musica
per l'anno scorso è andato vedremo tutto
interessate per studiare la x1 preparati